that man right there hopes to change the
fortunes for the tigers not only this
year but for the future of the franchise
it is the most anticipated
debut of a detroit athlete in a long
long time certainly for the tigers casey
mize takes the mound for the first time
as a major leaguer he's not the only one
second time in league history that two
major league starters will oppose one
another from the first round in their
debuts here's nico goodrum one and two
from dunning
and a swing of the miss strike three
first strikeout keep that baseball dane
dunning and get it to the authenticator
strikeout number one goes through mon
kata
and into a case at the dunning family
home casey mize readies for a potent
chicago lineup
he's considered the eighth best prostic
prospect in the majors and casey is a
kid number one draft choice number one
one in the country out of auburn
university
one two to moncada oh got him save that
one first of many in his major league
career here's eloy jimenez and here's
the 2-2 swung on and missed a couple of
strikeouts in the first inning of his
first major league game he can now take
a deep breath pitch to victor reyes the
two two swinging a miss force fema
running away or two sooner that ran away
but not down that brings up jorge
bonifacio bonafassi awaiting swinging a
minute slider with terrific late break
at the plate carnacion 2 for 14 against
tigers pitching this year
edwin a blast
deep left field the only question is it
fair yes sir
home run number 12 since sunday
and the parent gets a ride around the
base path
watch this he goes like that now watch
encarnacion
he goes cement mixer doesn't break
looking for another breaking ball and
the same at bat gets it it doesn't break
hits it out of the park he showed you
exactly what he was looking for here is
zach collins then they got it first base
strike three that splitter for casey
mize has been doing a number tonight
so grayson griner will lead off the
third inning for the tigers
there's a check swing and strike three
dunning's got four strikeouts through
seven outs that brings up isak paredes
swinging a miss strike three that
curveball absolutely snapped away and
veered into the dirt candelario who led
the game off with a double to right
oh another absolutely lethal breaking
ball six strikeouts for dane donaghy
strikes out the side here in the third
brings up jamer candelario two on one
out tigers down one nothing first here's
the 01.
[Applause]
lifts it to deep right
back goes mazzara
back goes angle and that ball's gone a
three-run shot for jamer candelario and
he screams let's go
boy
you know that's
that's one of those
thrillers for an outfielder
he's down right to the wall he knows he
gets to leap and make make himself a
hero rob the hitter
game of inches
this one won by chamber candelaria that
gives casey mize and the tigers the lead
third time he faces tim anderson tonight
into left field ozzie thank you tim
anderson as an rbi base hit and the sox
are within one tim bleeds it through the
left side of the infield three to two is
your score
monkana slashes to right field that's
down a base hit
bonifazio drops the ball monkatta gets
to second this game is tied so we'll
break you to bat
jose right field well struck toward the
wall
out of here
bring him home the first hit since the
fifth inning
it's off the soto and the sox lead 4-3
tim loves it
that is the fifth home run the 17th
driven in
the second hit of the night for jose and
a towering fly ball to right field
how about it edwin
that falls crack to left field
way back
bring in the parrot again
chuck was right
5-3 sucks
in the eighth
but the ford home run replay will show
you he should have stayed with the
parrot
two home runs tonight
one in the second one in the eighth and
neither
a doubt
there's the parrot what did chuck find a
new bird friend
[Applause]
right field mizara and the sox have won
the first three against the tigers four
in a row overall and the sox are now 14
and 11. going for the sweep of four
tomorrow behind geo